[Music]
what do you actually mean by pay
transparency
pay transparency is about the right to
information on pay and making workers
aware of any difference
there may be between their pay and the
average pay
of co-workers of the other sex
performing equal work
or work of equal value for the same
employer
at employers level it is about analyzing
pay structures compare work of equal
value and ensure
that the equal pay principle is
respected
how does the european commission intend
to collect statistics on the pay gap
between women and men the computation of
the gender pay gap at eu level relies on
the data collected
by eurostat and provided by member
states
do you think a sector approach could
make things easier on the very still
taboo
but important theme of paid transparency
the point of reference for the measures
in this proposal
is the individual employer the proposal
does not foresee
a sector-wide approach but more pay
transparency will foster pay systems
free from discrimination and gender
buyers and will help businesses to
attract
and retain talent what are the eu
institutions doing to promote pay
transparency and equal pay
internally the basic salary of staff
of the eu institutions is defined based
on gender-neutral criteria set out in
salary grids
which are set by the staff regulations
and
are publicly available